taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like
two fools gonna fight but only one food
can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds hey what's up hey
we did it we did it we did it episode
one
this is the taste buds podcast that's
right oh my god i'm so excited about
this
me too we are excited about this me too
yeah so sal volcano
joe derosa all right so me and joe let's
give him a little backstory okay
yeah this is the impetus this is the
origin story of this
yes joe and i are good friends in real
life very close
we spend a lot of time together um i
mean everything from we're gonna make it
sound like
we're 10 years old but everything from
sleepovers
to like we go on vacation together and
what have you yes
um yeah it's a real good feel it's kind
of it is it is
showing the pictures of them all the
stuff they do together exactly
yeah you make sauce i watch you you
really yeah and you're like slicing the
the
you're slicing the garlic with a razor
i'm playing music in the background i
crack open wine
yeah yeah yeah beautiful it's a real
thing we do
and one thing that we always i mean
you are one of my favorite people to
talk to because we i love
conversating with you is great because
when we agree on something it's fun
and then when we disagree on something
it's probably even more fun
yeah and there's only two things you
could do agree or disagree with someone
right
so we're always having fun right we just
love bullshitting and
we're cut from the same passionate cloth
there's very little we're indifferent
about it's a lot of strong
feelings one way or the other and one of
the things we argue about a lot is
food yes uh we've had some real
knock down drag outs about food about
food which cookies better which pie is
the best that kind of thing
and it was i've al i've said to sal many
times i go
the the birth of our friendship we were
already pals but the birth of our
friendship was
we were i was on the joker's cruise and
we got into this thing about cookies
that really launched the idea for all
this
that was so intense yeah that i was like
i'm going to be friends with this guy
forever like
i can't believe another thing is none of
us will shy away
we will talk about cookies for for three
hours straight like this
we're very meticulous like we will dig
in
and really like people will people but
some people will be like oh jesus enough
already
right we will we'll stay at it yeah and
and i and i
that's for everything like if i have we
also have tough times making decisions
would you say that
yeah it's uh now and i like to send each
other audio messages
instead of text and these things are
just rambling
on both for both of us just rambling
messes through the bra
the bush it's like trying to get through
the jungle with a machine if people
don't know about this
there's these things on um iphones i
suppose yeah where there's this little
arrow next to where you
text and if you just hold it if you just
hold it it'll record you and then you
let go
and you could send that so it's like a
voicemail but in a text form
and then it goes away after like two
minutes yeah and um
since we by nature are very wordy when
we talk
and we like to have a lot of we like to
like just really really really get every
detail
it works for us yeah cause our messages
are can be 10 20 seconds
or one minute two minutes three minutes
and the record what was the record
your record was seven seven forty seven
forty five the record
which is crazy and now you do realize if
you open that we love talking like this
because you really
also tone gets misconstrued on texts
yeah and should we have had some
whiskeys for this
tone gets miscons would you like a
whiskey yeah but we can wait till the
next we'll wait till next episode all
right
but yes i just wonder if you want one
yeah um but yeah yeah
but you really get the oomph and you get
to you get to like really like deliver
the what you're saying
yeah so so here's the thing here's the
based on everything we're saying
yeah okay what this show is gonna be
is we want to bring these food debates
and the public for two reasons number
one
uh we want to capture this what thing
that goes on between us
on camera and on audio and everything
because people get pulled in yeah
whoever's around us gets pulled in all
the time and we're always basing our
answers off everyone we're polling
everyone that's
with us and everything exactly so uh and
then also too
both of us think we're 100 right when we
argue this
which is also why we pull people in so
we came up with the idea for the show
taste buds we're going to debate one of
these food things every week
most of the time sometimes we might
stray and do other food related stuff
but we're going to debate one of these
things every week uh
and we're gonna put a poll up take it to
the people yeah on twitter twitter polls
which we've already done anyway as we're
arguing these things yes
i've had people text me and go is
everything okay
why did you launch seven twitter polls
today
if you see me or him if you see like
multiple polls in in a certain amount of
time it's me and him
arguing china is right
but uh yeah so so so we what we do is
we'll
we'll we'll state what versus what at
the beginning
who you're arguing for who i'm arguing
for right at the beginning we will put a
twitter poll out we will then continue
the debates
and then toward the end at the end we
will check the ball in a segment we're
calling
i think humble pie absolutely
because someone's gonna go down in
flames and has to eat the whole pie at
the end and then at the end we will
check the twitter poll and the twitter
poll will stand this law
yes except maybe and i just thought this
because we're all thinking this as we go
but
maybe just like the greatest battles in
heavyweights history
maybe one day we might want to have a
rematch and see if the cards weren't
going your way maybe
if something's close enough maybe there
could be a reason it'll get revisited
maybe even a rubber match yeah
yeah some of these will be revisited now
we we're gonna
keep some kind of time on these episodes
what are we at now mike
we're about six minutes beautiful i say
we get into this thing yeah
we're gonna hover around the 30-minute
mark with these episodes that's right we
want to get in you're here and get out
yeah it's fun it's light it's about food
and i feel little of these arguments
will go a long way
they will i just want to give you props
too for taste buds
because we racked our brain to what
we're going to call this thing yes and
we first we thought food fight
yeah which i think is really good but
it's a little generic and it was taken
by a billion people
a billion reasons it was like four pogba
and we had a list of dozens and dozens
of names and then you said taste buds
and we looked at each other and we're
like
wow aren't aren't we cute and
and aren't we witty and if you remember
we were on vacation when we came up with
this yes and we were sitting in the
living room of the place we're staying
at
and we were bouncing titles back and
forth it was about 10 30 in the morning
we're bouncing titles back and forth and
then sal just goes
can i stop you for a second and i go
yeah and he goes should we be doing this
in the pool with an ice cold beer
and i stood up and we walked to each
other and we hugged
and you said don't you ever move to los
angeles ever again that's true
that's true we lost you over there for a
while what a great moment
all right all right launch this poll uh
here we go so you might have known by
the episode name i don't know but uh
we are doing traditional
chips ahoy by nabisco
versus the oreo cookie yeah okay
so i'm gonna put up this twitter poll
now and basically
joe go ahead you'll be i already don't
like the way you introduce
because you're already throwing shade at
my side you're already doing it
i'm chip i'm team chips ahoy all the way
you're insane and i'm being clear i just
want to be clear that it is not
it doesn't mean chocolate chip cookie
it's not the roy
the generic like chocolate but you can
get a chocolate cookie from 100
different manufacturers from a bakery
that is an all-time class you did say
you planted things you said
traditional chips ahoy by nabisco which
puts ideas in people's heads
versus the oreo cookie which makes it
sound very mythic
uh you know well i said the oreo because
i can't say versus
oreo cookie oreo cookies chips versus
oreo cookies versus oreo
okay fine well it is what it is right
but all i'm saying is
is that people sometimes think it is a
chocolate chip so i had to write i had
to write here
chips ahoy brand cookie oreo brand
cookie why do you want
you tell me you tell me what you think
will help you in this
drubbing that you're about to get tell
me
tell me tell me how you want to piece
the words together to give yourself
a little percentage extra standard chips
ahoy
versus standard oreo standard chips ahoy
cookie versus standard oreo cookie
ahoy cookie and then which is better
jesus lord i went i we're over by one
standard chips ahoy cookie
goes over by one in the poll and it gets
red and blue
just write better cookie chips ahoy oreo
that's it
they'll know what it means nobody's
nobody's going to pick the [ __ ]
uh you know the the the chips ahoy that
they put like gummy bears in one time
you know what i mean they know what
we're talking about here i honestly
think
that we have to say at least who makes
oreo mike
is it i should why why is that also
nabisco
so that oh so they're in bed with both
these cookies
wait a minute who makes ships ahoy the
bisco
wait a minute oreo is nabisco
oh now you feel differently no but but i
didn't know that they were in the same
chips ahoy they're both in the biscuit
holy [ __ ]
so i'm gonna put nabisco chips ahoy
nabisco oreo cookie
but people are going to be like what's
in the biscuit out of it
it's you're going to confuse people just
put which is the better cookie
chips ahoy oreo so you think saying
chips ahoy
do i put the exclamation point i
i don't even understand these questions
you're asking well chips ahoy in the
proper title has an exclamation point
no because it because nobody knows that
it's going to look like you're pushing
chips ahoy you're right that's why i'm
asking no no no i'm not against you with
everything
like we also are working together on
this podcast
like i'm i'm letting you know i don't
want the edge no no no okay
it's just chips okay remember he said he
can't make decisions
would you feel do you feel mike that if
you read these two that you know i mean
the packaged
standard traditional chips ahoy
cookie in the blue thing now because
some people go well chips ahoy because
you can get
soft and you can get this no no no no no
no no
they're they say that they can say that
with oreo and they're going to go but i
love the pumpkin oreos okay
i'm going to go original trip to high
original oreo everything so see what
happens when we
combine these
but originals gonna you think standard
put you over the edge but original is
not going to
that's going to be too many letters
again original chips ahoy original
orange
no because you put i put cookie at the
end you said you said standard chips
ahoy cookie
oh okay okay i think standard i think
original is the better nomenclature
that's great
did i use that right yeah okay look
better cooking time
tahigo get a shot better cookie
original chips ahoy original oreo
twitter poll
and i'm tweeting this is a this is a
historic moment for you and i
yeah this is what started off it is
launch it and turn that phone upside
down
okay now let me tell you this hold on a
second
let me just ask you one other thing they
allow you to set the timer all the way
from one minute
to one week do i put
in a 30-minute poll or do i just put it
when we're done we're done
we're done okay so one day poll though
this is where it's going to get
interesting
30 minutes is where we're calling it but
if it's a real
test okay if it's a real you know bob's
your uncle
we might be at we might be 51 50 50 well
that would be impossible yeah
49 51 at 30 minutes and
one of us wins and then we revisit later
and the tides
we set it at a week no i'm doing it for
a day okay
but i'm just saying later tonight okay
what happens if the tables are turned
the official ruling's 30 minutes can
revisit
we can revisit at a later episode that
would really be a great indicator as to
whether we should have a rematch
that's what i'm saying said it at a week
okay just let it run
but i think yet there's a week people
are seeing this tweet in a week from now
i don't know no i'm gonna do a day and
god bless us all
i tweeted it all right historic moment
upside down ever taste buds poll
let the great food debate begin
uh now everybody already knows i'm chips
ahoy you're oreo yeah yeah
yeah uh now look go ahead because you
know i already can tell by the smirk
that i know you believe it i know that
you believe it i really do because we've
had
fights on the on the bowels of a cruise
ship together
but but i can i already feel like you're
you took a deep breath because you have
to convince people now
i feel like you're kind of convinced i
feel you know what i feel is how
strongly i feel
good i feel that you can do your whole
dissertation on chips ahoy i could look
at the camera be like
oreo that's what you think
that's what you think that's what you
think i think my job i think you're
gonna do heavy lifting today
and i think i'm using a hand truck the
arrogance
the arrogance of the people that love
this cookie
and it's not a great cookie you're
grouping us all in like we're talking
about red sox yankees yes
not every oreo person is is this this uh
i'm going to tell you this
i said it to you yesterday on the audio
message i said i would say it today on
the episode you should have saved that
message
i wouldn't cross the street for an oreo
what do you think of that
what do you think of that i'm sorry we
know what i think you just you just
claimed arrogance on me and then you
drop a statement like that
i need two chalk i need two chalky
wafers
with sugar cream in the middle oh really
so you need so the first thing out of
your mouth is an attack on the oreos
yeah of course it is a mudsling
you're not but you're not by the way
gonna defend the chips ahoy first i'll
defend the chips ahoy
it's a perfect chocolate chip cookie
there's just enough crunch
there's just enough give it's a
chocolate chip cookie which
in the realm of cookies is the greatest
kind of cookie
that has ever existed a chocolate chip
don't hit your chips ahoy wagon to the
chocolate chip
chips wagon because a chocolate chip
is its own thing a chips ahoy is a
version of it granted i'll give you that
look i'm not even nabisco chips away
people i'm not even against
i don't not like chips ahoy
i will say and if i'm being honest i'm
sorry but i have to be honest it's all i
could be really yeah
good uh i feel the quality of a chips
ahoy has fallen off
as as has most products
uh food products since i was younger
devil dogs aren't the same
candy bars aren't the same cereals
aren't the same even tropicana went from
64 to 59 ounces right underneath our
notes
okay now chips ahoy were bigger they had
more chips and and now i find a lot of
time chips oh you're getting an under
baked batch
and don't confuse that with soft baked
don't give use yeah you can pull it out
of chips ahoy it should be a really
golden brown
a lot of times you pull it out and it's
just about chalky white look in the
mirror my friend
it's chalky white and it is bursting
with chips the campaign was like
you can't take a bite without a chip i
pull out a chips ahoy
right now and i don't even recognize it
okay when i was young let me tell you
this
only a fool wants it bursting with chips
because
somebody knows somebody that knows a
chocolate chip cookie somebody knows the
value of a cookie
knows that when those those bites with
less chip
and a little extra cookie versus the
bites with more chip and a little less
cookie
that's what it's all about your toes
that's what it's all when you take a
bite without it you then appreciate the
bite with it that much more it's why
it's why a chocolate cookie with
chocolate chips in it can go take a
flying leap as far as i'm concerned
it's too much it's too it's chocolate on
chocolate what am i an animal
break it up a little bit give me a
little bit of a blend you know what i
mean you put peanut butter with jelly
you don't need a peanut butter sandwich
now you just shifted your argument and
it was cute what you did but now you
shifted it
to having a blend of cookie and a blend
of chocolate chip
but what i'm telling you is it you could
still have a blend of those two things
and it'd still be
a little bit lacking in the chocolate
chip area and by the way
chip is in the name they're not they're
not ahoy
they're not they're not which by the way
we recently realized it was a reference
to ships ahoy and neither of us ever
realized blew my mind
blew my mind it's a nautical deemed
chocolate chip cookie pick a lane
i mean and not a hint of nautical
on the package chips ahoy i mean that's
what it's saying
ships ahoy chips it means chips it means
if there's one thing you're getting it's
chips not chiplets by the way you're
wrong
look at the picture of the old chips
ahoy
from clearly the 50s or 60s whatever
that is there's not more chips back then
oh buddy those are beautiful morsels
just perched on top calling the new ones
the new ones look great
i mean if we could show this i mean
you're showing
first of all you're crazy and i'll tell
you why you're crazy i'm joe joe look at
me look at me i want this to be fair too
yeah so i'm gonna point out your own
mistake
you're comparing the picture they took
for the
package which you know was a hole to do
that was lighting that was moving that
should have been the best picture you'd
ever put on the front you think they're
putting worse
versions you just compared it to someone
who opened their chips ahoy package and
snapped a picture of it
on their phone i'm saying oh that one
down here look at all of them i'm saying
if you look at the package picture from
the 50s it is not
more chips back then it's more golden
brown okay well i will tell you
something right now i will tell you
something right now
see the picture that they have right
there see that picture on the top of the
chips ahoy box
you open that you pull the sleeve out
you open that white plastic you pull out
a chocolate chip you put it next to that
cookie
they do not look the same my friend they
do not that is a glamour cookie shot
that is a glamour shot like he just
graduated high school
mike give me a picture of an actual
chips ahoy out of the box
on the table so we can show sally's
wrong right now
okay show me an actual cookie look at
the cookies on the package
that is perfectly symmetrical a bite
with
every single chocolate chip they're deep
they're rich the cookie's golden brown
you do not want to do this to yourself i
do i don't you don't want to be trying
to do it to myself
you don't want to pull out a chips ahoy
i'm dying to do this to myself pull one
out
but look this is the thing it's look at
those [ __ ] things they're beautiful
that's the cgi cookie joe that's not
someone's real picture joe
all right show me a real one ha ha ha ha
show me a real one look at that
show me a real look at this okay there's
a real one right there broken in half
but bro if you think that's the same you
are you you need you that is insane
as a matter of fact the one underneath
it that's not broken i don't see a chip
i don't even see a chip now let's
let's you want to know what looks
identical identical
to the package knock knock who's there
it's the oreo
look at that that's an oreo and that's
what it looks like on the package and
that's what it looks like in the box
that's right
it's a cookie it's punched it has the
ridges it has a thing
that is exactly you're getting what you
pay for every time first of all
i will say first of all the crest
imprinted on the cookie
has always depressed me it looks like
something that would hang over a
courthouse or a church or something
it makes me very sad when i look at it
that is there's nothing fun about it
at all there's nothing fun about this
cookie this cookie looks like it came
from the great depression
it did it didn't change since 1930
that's because it didn't nato
it didn't change by the way we're
talking about the originals only but
oreos
they there's a lot going on with oreos
right now well tell me what's going on
because i've really presented the case
for the chips ahoy it's a crisp cookie
it's got enough give that it doesn't
need to be a softie
it's got a nice balance so you're
talking about it in his best form chip
chips versus cookie flavor
and you can barrel a sleeve of them like
no other i mean it's
you do your barrel a sleeve of chips
ahoy better than you can barrel a sleeve
of oreos watch me
okay let me touch me i could do one
arguing that's how easy let me talk a
little look at that look at that
let me hit that let me let me talk a
little about the oreo which one of those
plates looks better to you you're going
to tell me
that [ __ ] brown mess on the left
looks better to you
i don't think the chips away i don't
care i'm not talking about what looks
better i'm talking about what tastes
like what looks more appetizing to you
the oreos
because i know how they taste okay the
oreo is so good it didn't need to change
okay it hasn't done anything you know
what the oreo is there's no other cookie
you couldn't name another cookie i
challenge anyone to name another cookie
that has permeated so many other
products
because they want to latch on to what
the oreo has to offer
cookies and cream ice cream is based
every major
outlet has it 31 flavors ben and jerry
haagen-dazs
your local groceries and cream ice cream
is chunks of oreos horribly boring ice
cream you're insane
it's it's a it's a candidate for best
ice cream everybody knows that i'm not
going to argue with you
what i'm not saying it's mine but
cookies and cream i bet you cookies and
cream is the most sold over vanilla or
chocolate it's the most sauce ice cream
hands down guess what ice cream is way
better take a wild guess
chocolate chip cookie dough no way a
thousand
i promise you that that cookies and
cream aka oreos in
cook cream it sells more than cookie
dough ice cream i guarantee you by the
way
did you see the product that was just up
on the screen for two seconds no
uh they made chips ahoy that have oreo
cream
inside the chips ahoy i wonder why
because chips
ask yourself that question because chips
ahoy said you can come into my house if
you want
you're in my house i'm not coming into
yours you think i'm going to let your
cookie surround me oh is that is that
how you want to spin it you
spinster that's not a spin you're a spit
you spun it
they're like we need what oreo has
that's the secret ingredient everyone
loves we need to have that
to even be able to compete with them to
walk in the door to put on the same
shoes as oreo
oreo is also by the way oreo is in
everything let me tell you oreo is
they've taken oreos and put a blizzards
and shakes
and ice creams and oreo cookie pie
wow talk to you about that oreo crust
okay now this is the this is the failed
argument
ladies and gentlemen this is the failed
ailing argument
of every oreo fan look how diverse it is
look at all they do with it look i can
do a lot with breadcrumbs i don't want
to eat them out of the [ __ ]
can do you understand what i'm saying
okay an oreo is a better
useless ingredient an oreo is better
than a chips ahoy
please a chip soy cookie in every way
please wow
bryce knows what they're doing brian's
teamed up with nabisco to do it
two-in-one
and they split the oreo cookies and
cream and the chips only half and half
all right i mean bro
briars is work obviously working on
another level but here's what i have to
say to you okay
it's a better experience all around
eating an oreo i enjoy it it's more of a
i have a ritual with an oreos
i have choices give it to me i can bite
it just like that just bite it like a
sandwich because it's a cookie sandwich
by the way
it's not just a cookie it's diverse it
has versatility it's the worst version
of an ice cream sandwich
i could twist it off i could eat one
side without cream
and then i could eat the other side with
the cream i could twist it off and eat
one side without cream
then just eat cream and then eat the
other side without cream
i could it dunks better oreo has the
perfect dunk you don't wait too long
you dunk it in and you can pull it out
and you can really really control
if you're getting a crunch if you're
getting a sog i'll tell you another
thing another thing i like i like
leaving well
if i lose one because sometimes it
happens i'm not perfect but if i lose
one and one goes in there
sometimes i don't even fish for it why i
let it be
i let it get in the milk i let it swirl
around i let chunks go at little treats
or i won't even swirl i won't even swirl
i'll eat the rest of my i'll dunk the
rest and then i get to the bottom of the
milk
and it's down there like the titanic
okay and it either goes in my mouth with
the last drop of milk or i drink all the
milk it's stuck to the bottom i take a
spoon
i dip in and i have what is like a
basically an
oreo a soft oreo bursting with no what
i'm saying is
i can choose any of these things but
again you're
talking about and and i've used this
argument with you before
i said if i go to a place if i go to
let's say
uh a taco bell and i go taco bell is the
best burritos
and you go okay let's go get one and
then i go in i get a taco bell burrito
with seven different ingredients in it
and then i open the
burrito up i take out the beans i put
them on the side
i throw the lettuce in the trash i add
sauce
i say it's too much sour cream whatever
and then i remake the burrito
that's not the best burrito that's a
thing i don't know
i was able to fashion with ingredients
i don't even know how to apply what you
just said to this conversation
it's wildly awesome no it's not
and oreo is the same i'm eating the same
thing i'm just choosing how to eat it
there's no wrong way to eat an oreo
sorry reese's you shouldn't have to
deconstruct
deconstruction i'm saying there's the
option i didn't say i had to
i didn't say i can't i can't eat an oreo
unless i lick the cream
and then i eat the two things separate
oh i'm all i'm saying is you have
options you know what you could do with
a chips oh you bite it you chew it and
you swallow and you go
jesus christ what an amazing cookie that
i just got my money
on the versatility of the oreo it means
nothing what you just said about by the
way about the burrito
well you just said it it does not apply
that is one of the worst arguments you
know what's perfect now
people based on our arguments like like
this is our closing arguments
you would have went down in flames with
that it's a perfect analogy because
every example you've given so far about
why you love the oreo
involves some sort of variation of the
cookie
you have yet to say you get to say
i can sit down dry
no first thing i said no manipulation i
said
no manipulation go back to the tape
first thing i said you said you need a
sleeve of them before you sleep with
chips away
i said when i started to talk about it
right now and we can go back and we can
i will make him go back
and i said i could i could buy it cold
just i bite it just out of the package
like a sandwich you said you
oh yeah i know you said that you said
you could you said you could and i could
do all that it doesn't sound like you
like to
and it sounds like you need to
manipulate your cookie to make it an
enjoyable experience i know i don't
that's what it sounds like i don't know
it doesn't oh
i want to express i want to experience
all the breaths of what the oreo has to
offer
i want to i want to take it in every
which way okay that's like saying you
know what you just said
the burrito thing's ridiculous what you
should have said was like okay if i give
you a plate of rice
and you take a medium scoop and eat it
first time but in the second time you
decide to take a much bigger scoop
why what's not good enough about that
rice that's not what i did i'm just
eating it's the same freaking
ingredients bro
no if you told me that you like to take
if you
were
if you told me that you like to take um
a toothpick and pop out an oreo chip or
a morsel
of a chocolate chip and eat it and take
one out and eat it and take all the
surface
ones out and eat it i wouldn't be like
well that's not a chips ahoy
you're just doing it the way you want to
do this no your argument is this
my favorite food is a cheesesteak i love
a cheesesteak because what i do most of
the time with the cheesesteak is i get
it
i take the roll off i eat the meat by
itself
i drink the liquidy cheese separately
then i eat the roll at the end
because oh what a great versatile thing
you can't you can't con
you can't compare a hoagie with 10
ingredients and beef in it
the fact that you just called a hoagie i
called it because you're from philly
no you're from philly you say holy [ __ ]
not a hoagie my friend i know it takes
that background
stupid stuff like hoagie and submarine
sandwich and grinder
i say it's a hero all i say is hoagie
cheesesteak hero all i say is hoagie
which is the right word for it but but
joe you know when you're trying
to argue with someone who's irrational
and you want to blow your brains out
yeah
you can't make this dumb cheesesteak
argument
to the oreo i'm eating the ingredient
there's different ways to enjoy an oreo
and no matter what the same thing i'm
swallowing is what i started with i'm
not pulling out ingredients
you're ridiculous bro you're ridiculous
i'm talking tent
for ted one on one of the live show i
wish we did this in front of a live
audience
so you could hear them scowled
head-to-head out of the box
this chip's always a stronger cookie it
stands on its own two feet better
oh it doesn't all right let's take it to
the polls it does not i'm trying to feel
i'm trying to remember if i want to hit
you with anything else before we go to
the polls it's time to eat crow
let's see who won this one oh my look
there's even
milk on the oreos package because people
are like yeah they know it can't stand
by itself
because they go they go i know it's not
a great cookie but look you can eat it
with milk
that's what that is you're crazy not a
[ __ ] thing on that chips ahoy
except a huge bite out of the cookie
because they know it's so good
okay they know it's so good they're
showing you you have to mesh this cookie
with something else
that's [ __ ] and i'll tell you
another thing i'll tell you another
thing i'll go out on a limb and say i
won by a
i don't know what our margins are going
to be but i'm telling you right now it
ain't going to be close
okay i'm saying i'm calling minimum
oreos in the 60s
minimum now put your money where your
chips ahoy is tell me what you think
it's going to be because i'm telling you
this is going to be what the
what the what the what the paper would
call a drubbing and when they write
about a team beating another team and
it's really big i'm not
if i'm not the winner it's not going to
be the first time
i went against public opinion and was a
better person for doing it i don't care
i don't care but what you're saying is
that you're right and it's better
so if that's true then everyone will
believe like agree with we've
for the most part in terms of majority
we'll see
i mean we'll see all right that's the
point of this right here we go
here we go are you ready because this is
also a big moment in this
show because this is going to set the
tone this is the first this is going to
step forward
first step is because you run this is
all about momentum too yeah okay it's
all about momentum okay
i'm amped what do we got i am i am too
and
here we go and
after almost 6
000 votes okay you're winner
and still
cookie the bisco cookie champagne
the oreo is drubbing it's a drumming as
i
called just remember this first episode
62-38 i even called
that we'd be in the 60s i was that
confident and i backed it up
this is insane 62-38 659 votes okay
17 minutes in okay okay
why don't i read some some comments okay
we never realized that because this uh
i'll read and i'm gonna be
there's no i'll read both if there's
people [ __ ] you know
here's someone chips ahoy dunked that
cookie and milk for five seconds it was
heaven they taste weird now though
i told you they fell off and this is
nothing against
chips ahoy everyone did it but the
second comment down
is echoing a sentiment i said joe
well congrats you know what else hasn't
changed securities
racism that's about you know what not in
the oreo cookie black and white baby
black and white together okay i prefer
chewy chips ahoy original the original
hurt my teeth
okay the original hurt this is a mood
dependent question they serve different
purposes
not okay i can see that i'm gonna read a
few when is the last time anyone got
original oreos instead of double stuff
that's
not applied here this might be the
toughest question i've ever seen
all right you need milk to enjoy oreos
chips ahoy is good with or without no
competition
only chewy chips ahoy not regular i'm
not ashamed to admit that i can murder a
bag of chips ahoy alone
yep okay now it sounds like the comments
are on my side even though i lost the
hardest decision of my life
depends entirely if i have milk or not
original oreo
also the giant ice cream oreo legit i'm
not even voting because it's too hard
for me to choose
chips ahoy is better hands down oreos
always taste like stale plastic
okay you can take a walk thank you
okay hold on oreo you can twist it and
link it or
dunk it in milk the [ __ ] package says
milk's favorite oreos are so overrated
chips ahoy all the way
okay so og chips ahoy is honestly awful
the new chunky chip toy is better chips
ahoy
nowadays okay here we go chips ahoy
nowadays are the biggest disappointment
i have no idea what they did to them but
they are weak and taste weird
and every couple of months i hope it
goes back to deliciousness and i buy
them again and they still suck and i am
sad thank you
you know so you have arguments for both
some guys who is out here picking dry
ass chips ahoy over the blessing that is
oreo
blessing smh blessing smdh
blessing blessing flavorless cream
between two chalky cookies
chips ahoy's the goat
it is uh
i'm so tired as twist argument
i mean you know people people i will
tell you people also are going
very hard they're either like love one
and hate the other
so we picked a very passionate um first
topic
all right so 1-0 babe
that's our app yeah this is what it's
going to be this is what it's going to
be so
it's a lot of fun i'm excited
we burned 35 minutes arguing and i have
more i had more to say but
i don't need to though because we we put
it to bed
it's not even fit for a rematch at 62-38
not even fit for a rematch
let it go for the next day hold on all
right uh i still love you
i love you of course that's why we're
doing it yeah i was trying to sign off
like a cool little thing
i was gonna still love it oh yeah let's
plug yeah uh
without a country podcast my podcast for
corinne fisher and myself
available on gas digital network uh use
promo code wac get yourself a free month
uh available there exclusively every
tuesday and everywhere you get your
podcast every saturday
uh and pat walsh myself doing we'll see
you in hell reviewing movies
uh of all genres uh new episodes on
patreon
and only and the entire back catalog on
uh starboard's media wherever you get
your podcast you should
you guys should rev you guys should
review the doc on how chip's always the
greatest cookie oh wait it doesn't exist
so
you think this will come out before
august 22nd
i don't know okay well [ __ ] i don't know
but who all right yeah depending i have
a show at cape cod drive-in i'm doing
stand-up
august 22nd in cape cod uh if not we can
cut it out
and um yeah so and this and so um
yeah so we have dinner party which is on
now thursday nights at 10.
misery index is coming back with season
three joker's to come back so all that
stuff you already know but another new
one
i'm doing a podcast with chris stefano
called hey babe
and it'll be on the same channel as this
one and uh that's it that was
crazy fun i like i'm ready like i'm
ready to battle you like alright i'm
ready to do this
i caught oh this was i think even hey
babe was crazy funny so this
this was great hey babe was too but no
it was i caught the end of it today and
i thought it was really funny
thanks buddy but uh yeah this was great
i'm ready to go let's do it
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like
two foods gonna fight but only one food
can be right taste buds man yeah they're
coming to the mic i'm talking taste buds
taste buds